- We always close out the
show with one last story,
to lift your spirits
and brighten your day,
and all February in honor
of black history month,
we are shining a light
on African-Americans
bringing joy, enrichment
and compassion to the world.
This is What I'm Liking.
So I want to tell y'all about a former
college football player turned
psychology PhD candidate,
who's getting kids excited to go to
historically black
colleges and universities.
It's all through his new
book, H is for HBCUs.
Not only does the book
help kids learn to read
it also teaches them how
HBCUs have helped mold
Some of the nation's most
renowned change makers.
I'm talking about greats
like Kamala Harris,
Oprah Winfrey, and
Martin Luther king, Jr..
My gosh.
We have the author on the line right now,
dialing in from Nashville where he watches
on news channel five.
Hi Henry.
- How did you come up with
the idea for the book?
- Yes, so my siblings went to HBCUs
and I didn't cause I
went and played football
at a PWI full scholarship.
So I was there when there were a lot
of racial injustice and you know,
just a lot of different plights that
we were going through as black people
that I didn't feel comfortable
were seen or have a voice.
So a lot of my times my
siblings would talk about
how they felt seen and heard and
that community they had,
so when I decided to go
to HBC for grad school,
Tennessee State was the perfect fit.
I met great mentors.
I met, you know, people of
color that looked like me,
that thought like me,
that we could collab with.
And I really felt that same sense of love
and that mentorship I received.
So I wanted to start that at an early age
for young children starting
at pre-K, kindergarten
to get that exposure and hopefully
they'll choose the HBCU
when it comes that time.
- Oh, that's amazing.
So can you tell us more,
I love that picture.
Can you tell us more
about what's in the book?
- Yeah, so the book is from A to Z,
each letter is connected to an
historically black college or university
or prominent African-American
that went there.
So we've got people like Lonnie Johnson,
the inventor of the Super Soaker
who some black kids didn't know
he invented the Super Soaker.
We've also got a gospel
legend Yolanda Adams
who went to Texas Southern.
So, and Kamala Harris,
we've got people like
Langston Hughes.
- Wow.
- We've got just all
sorts of different people.
We got sport athletes, we have
politicians, we have poets.
So just a lot of people that, you know,
just gives you a glimpse
and a little inkling
of who these people are,
why they're important and just hopefully
gain hat knowledge for HBCUs
and the people that went there.
- And also that confidence for,
for kids to see people that look like them
doing amazing things and that
they can accomplish that.
It's all around just a really great book
for any child, really.
Thank you so much, Henry.
Coming from a mom of two young kids,
I can not wait to read it with my kids.
I'm liking your post right now
and that's not all, my man.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show,
want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars
just 'cause you're rad.
- Oh wow.
I appreciate that so much.
Thank you.
- Absolutely, thank you so much Henry.